My name's Nicky Clayton
and I'm professor of comparative cognition at the University of Cambridge in the Psychology Department.
I'm also scientist in residence at one bed and dance company in London and.
When they're doing well it's the name OUR I am being sets it was called Ballet around there originally
and then it became a dance company.
And most recently they can use the name again to just from their own time because it dances around an orchestra.
And it's nineteen years old this year we've just celebrated our ninety's Bester. Really.
But you have a scientist in residence at a ballet thought that correct. Well Palin Complete don't want one.
You don't need a scientist.
Well I do things but mainly I collaborate with Mark Baldwin who is a Korea world famous choreographer
and artistic director of the company and we've worked on five corridor for works together.
One about evolution called the Committee of change one that was about crows and children and the power play.
Called sudden for secret ever to be told one about sexual conflict which was called what the X. To see.
So that's three of them and the most recent one that we're doing which will premiere shortly in July.
In fact is called the creation based on Haydn's creation it's about the origin of life and the origin of time.
So it's very movement based. So that's some of the sorts of things that we do.
Company and also work with some of the dancers on their individual choreograph projects. OK so what.
So what works when you put the emphasis on the science all of that. Because the integration of the chain. It's.
About using ideas from science to inspire you. Choreograph it works. So it's quite an interesting thing to do and.
Clive Wilkins with you my collaborator and I captured gotten stronger.
We were a tad paper together with another of my colleagues Kevin Leyland on the evolution of dance which was published
quite recently in Current Biology.
So all the work is interrelated it's about I suppose I'm a movement junkie really and I love to move I love to dance
and my science and art is really inspired by my love of dance and well of. Because I've always wanted to be a bad.
I've always wanted to fly. And I have invisible when you know that you can see that.
Yeah well let me go back to your professor at University. So so what can you tell me what. What exactly is your.
Department.
What do you do while I'm based in the department of psychology these days although my training initially was in
sewerage and so I read silage year to Oxford University
but I've always been interested in the interface between biology
and psychology because I'm interested in how they stink.
So they'd say logical aspect of it is because of the beds
and the psychological aspect which is that I'm interested in cognition
and I'm interested in what's it like to think without words as well as what it's like to think with words which is
something to explore scientifically in terms of the ability of birds in general
and members of the crow family in particular and their cognitive abilities their problems. Solving. So so your.
It's resin comes from. So why don't you. When I and the only other part from psychology.
You know
and you combine it with trying to find out how birds can think well crows in particular because crows are extremely
intelligent you've got huge brains for their body size relative to body size their brains yours are just those pansies.
And we know that they are extremely good problem solvers. The kinds of things that I've been investigating are.
Whether these birds are capable of remembering the past and thinking about the future.
So in other ways can they like us mentally travel backwards
and forwards in time to remember specific past separate sets and to imagine one crucial plan for future scenarios.
OK let me go back to define first what was it in your opinion is and.
Without thinking about birds but what do you think is thinking. Well.
I would define cognition as the ability to problem solve.
And it involves a series of scales that the kinds of things that I would I would want to include would be mental time
travel. And theory of mind. So these two skills are related.
So mental time travel is about being able to think about other times so times other than the hearing now.
Hence past and future and Theory of Mind is the ability to think about other nine S.
So I if I have theory of mind then I can understand that your perspective.
It will be similar to mine in some regards but in other ways it will be crucially different
and the idea that I could put myself in your shoes and imagine what your thinking would be theory of mind.
So I think two important.
Thinking skills you have a thinking skills but when you want the fine work is thinking what is the.
Well as I've said I thought oh I'm starving. This problem solving and so on. What is a thought.
So a soft is the ability to project the nine. So the problem with just defining problem solving.
As I could settle on one problem I've got here is I'm thirsty. I want to pick up this cup to drink the water.
Now you can say that the ability to hold the car can do this allows me to solve the problem of being thirsty.
Well that's a physical task
but that the point about thinking is that you can play multiple scenarios in the mind without actually executing the
class first so are having never encountered this kind of object before they're able to think through in the mind's eye
without taking any action. What is the minimal amount of things I need to do in order to drink the water.
So for example with the birds.
We have our own water task that involves something similar to this we call it the atoms fable because it's based on the
Arabs fable of the thirsty crow in the picture
and in the fable of course a crow encounters are a picture of water the water level is too low
and so it's it's not within reach and what Crowder's says she found some stones
and puts a sense into the picture to raise the water level to a level at which she can drink.
So we can do something similar with our we can present them with a Chub that's got some water in the water level is too
low for the bird to just be able to go and reach the water. In fact in our case we don't make the birds thirsty.
We floated little tasty worm on top of the water now works well
and a wax moth larvae as they're properly called a zero on a test
or the Belgian truffles of they called it well they really really love these
and so then highly motivated to get these worms
and of course the worms are out of the reach because the water levels too low.
And they bed spontaneously stones into the water level to raise water.
We can then use a task like that a basic problem solving task as well. How are the birds thinking through this problem.
How can they solve these things so for example we could have a series of tubes only one of which contains water.
Maybe in another condition the worm is floating in air.
Thanks to a bit of blue tap rather than real magic and in another one the worm is resting on a solid say sound
and we can ask whether the birds understand that there's no point putting stones into a cheaper lair
or too full of sand that's not going to change the level of the substrate it's only going to work with the liquid with
the water.
Similarly we can give them the choice of different kinds of objects to put into the tube
and asked whether they understand that it's heavy ones sink that are actually going to displace the water
and therefore. Allow the water level to rise to a level at which they can then reach the worm.
Whereas if they are hollow ones in the ones that use float. That's not going to displace them.
So we can do various tests like that to see how they're thinking through the problem
and that's our way of trying to get it how they can solve these problems and what they understand about the task.
But there you are talking about the core of it thermally I'm talking about Howard and Jerry is.
Roxanne you get an incredible one hundred languages Yeah but that's as an example you asked me.
There isn't a set definition you know I can't give you four words that nails down what thinking is because if I try
and do that there's going to be too many caveats to it you know given all that's why I want to start to think out loud
what could possibly be so that's why I think problem solving.
But one in which you can have sort of internal trial and error and think through a problem is concerned.
Yeah yeah well that's interesting for me sort of first I would like to try to find out.
Well what what the area we're talking about and after that.
I would like to talk with you about how do you do your research with. Crows and with young children.
So I think one different sort of really.
Not everything about thinking and cognition is very clear to me because our audience is well educated
but they are not scientists so. That's why we have to do to. Talk a little bit about what are we talking about.
Yes well in the reason I say gave problem solving said
but there are simple ways of problem solving that I wouldn't call thinking.
Would be you could imagine you just do something through trial
and error so you know you've no idea what this is it's a novel object and push it this way
and that doesn't work you need to do that.
Lots where can eventually through exploring a number of things you figure out that the best way to get a cup
and drink is to do that action and then they're after you just do more of the same.
Well that's called learning by trial and error or instrumental conditioning is what a psychologist would call that
and most people wouldn't want to call any problem solving that simply occurred through learning by trial
and error more instrumental conditioning cognition they would want to say that cognition.
Requires more than that it's the ability to actually sinks.
A problem without necessarily having to you to learn about the outcomes first.
So that's why I've used that example as a as a distinction so what you usually looking for is to train your animal
human subject on a particular task until they're doing it
and then you do some kind of transfer test which really what you're tapping into is what are they understood.
And how they do something more than just simple learning by rote can they obstruct some sort of general rule that tells
you that yes that they're actually thinking about it and it's not automatically doing it here
or are you so interesting interested in the circular. About how this works in your mind.
Well I suppose I'm fascinated by thinking and say.
And at one level I'm really interested in the different kinds of saw processes that.
Go on and the extent to which they rely on words or don't rely on words so.
I say words rather than language because of course in humans we have language.
And sometimes we think without using words
but I wouldn't want to say that that's without language because it's not like each take the bits of the brain that are
responsible for language on screen about the brain put them on the side and carry on.
You're still all your linguistic skills contribute to all your cell processes with and without words
but the whole idea that we might be able to the sum to which.
Words enrich our thought
but perhaps even more intriguingly the extent to which they can constrain also so I think it's a fascinating area to do.
If you meant you expressed. My thinking without words. What kind of.
Well ways of thinking contemporary dance visual art are both examples of thinking without words
or thinking largely without words when you see a beautiful painting it doesn't usually have words on it
and even if it does have a word on it like the famous this is not apparent.
Even then that the point is so much more than just the words right.
And similarly in contemporary dance you see a beautiful. Series of movements. But words are really secondary.
Yes it's quite a title and yes there might be a small description in the program but the performance is so much more
or do you do magic in fact that it's also largely without words I mean the patter that goes with the in fact is just a
small part of the at the at the bits that everybody gets.
Is when something unexpected happens when you realize that you can't possibly have seen what you thought you saw
or you must have not seen what really happened. Cybele Weisser those juxtapositions the beautiful painting.
Is this the artist had a thought and you try to express it in government again yesterday
and then the way in which you don't wonder what things artists actually saw what they actually saw
and why they chose to represent it in that particular way. So. You know Alan even with words.
I mean I think there's an interesting difference between scientific writing and literary artistic writing big.
As in scientific writing you want to make everything is on ambiguous as possible because the whole point of a
scientific paper is that strictly speaking anybody should be able to read the method section of their paper
and if they had the right skills
and facilities they should be able to replicate the funding so in a scientific paper you want to make everything.
As an ambiguous and clear as possible but very often in military writing.
You want to make it ambiguous because you want layers to it. You want the words not to be self-explanatory.
But to generate needful.
And the less I think that is an interesting contrast so you know way I think in really good literature
and the words are almost being used in the way.
No used by a composer to you know create a beautiful story to build which layers of.
Atmosphere much of which is largely wordless wordless writing mean you can have labels for emotions
but there's so much more to love war joy
or sorrow that there is to just the label of it you know in the same way as
when you see a beautiful piece of art you hear a gorgeous piece of music. All these feelings and thoughts.
You know swell up inside you. But the words are only secondary right.
It's there's a subjective experience going on inside the mind of the viewer are missing their own birth
and it's a it's a thought you think this is a thought if you see a beautiful brain you will be a full damsel voice.
So I think thoughts are heavily charged emotional thoughts are conscious thoughts.
I think they can be conscious and I think they can be unconscious for it.
You can have that unconscious feeling of just isn't this wonderful
and then you can actually have a real conscious thing and so.
You know
when you were talking earlier about the timing of the storytelling if if some sort of dramatic music comes at the wrong.
Time in the experience.
You're certainly very conscious of it by all of a sudden skeptical thoughts come into your head where you think that's
not right or I don't believe that or you see a bit of a film sequence it's out of sync and I stuffed up there.
And all of a sudden those things that perhaps were that were before him gets a prompt
or she would just sort of enjoying it but not really questioning
or your sauce all of a sudden it's it's like it switched and suddenly think power on a minute.
You know you're listening to no political politician speaking and all of a sudden you think. You shift all.
I don't believe you for one minute.
So you can be going back
and listen to three until she turns them said they are my find myself synced believing every word he says because he
has that kind of a voice where if he said. Nikki darling please jump off a cliff right now and commit suicide.
I be halfway there before I was even realizing it because he's got such a persuasive voice.
So you have a concert flip flopping you think between the cultures experience
and the unconscious one we prosecutor me as when Clive and I dance in town here. If you were to say to me afterwards.
What steps. The key dancer show me that move again I wouldn't remember. Because when we're dancing where. In the flow.
Which is connected together wheeling is one of the music that I'm not thinking oh he wants me to do it.
Backward option now or again show up on my brain doesn't work that way
and just say I'm just subconsciously just connecting with Clive.
I'm just moving together as well and synchrony to the music I'm not thinking about the moves and you often.
And obviously that's particularly the case in something like tango where it's such a connecting to
and improvised dance
but even in Korea graphic sequences often you know they were her song director saying to one of the Don't don't have
the same can't.
Because if you put too much conscious thought conscious cognition into the process he will in the fluidity of the
naturalists of the music itself as it was always an interesting juxtaposition between the conscious
and unconscious thoughts. You know that's very very interesting and maybe we. You can talk about it later. Because.
I would like to know because I just need to know how do you do your research about thinking.
Because our viewer doesn't know anything so. So now that the in the in this part.
I would like to feel the surprise that you research trials. You understand.
So you mean you'd like me to talk about an experiment that was surprising.
I don't know that know about but for our viewers. You know you you are you researched our mind about thinking.
But there of you don't know if you knew who. Crocus.
So when I ask you how do you do your research you want me to start when I work with crows. For example.
So I suppose one way to define thoughts. Would be that I'm interested in studying the mental lives.
And that it's see it's mental movements I suppose it's what's going on in the now and that I'm interested in
and I were mainly when you as humans.
And with crows and you might think well why crows or sexually monkeys I could understand that wire crab
or crows are extremely intelligent they have huge bones of the body size they're as big as. Chimpanzees.
In fact my husband scorn them for the Apes.
When it comes to their national abilities because they're so cognitively impressive.
And they're very they're very observant and very good problem solvers. So we.
The way in which we do the experiments or to give them a series of problem solving puzzles. If you like.
With a view to trying to systematically very second parameter is in order to try to get a handle on how they're
thinking how they're solving. Apparently definitely.
How do you know how do you know that cross theory because well because we can show that.
And so good at solving these problems and they can think about the past and the future.
For example we've been able to show in one experiment that they are kind of memories. They have fantastic memories.
So you can crack it which is an American Corvette that lives in the cemetery in a higher power the mountains hides on
average about thirty thousand seats a year and can remember the location of these thirty thousand caches
and people have tested their memories over periods of nine months and found no evidence of forgetting.
So they have really remarkable. I mean most of where they've hidden.
It's not really remember where we were at but this is a fantastic memories and.
Caching or the ability to hide food is a very interesting behavior for looking at aspects of cognition.
Because you can ask how good are the memories and you can show that if you remove the seeds
and we can possibly be using smell. They still go back to those particular places.
We've been able to show that they don't just remember where the food is hidden they can remember which kinds of food
were hidden where and how long ago so they can remember what happened where and when.
We've been able to show that they can even remember which particular individuals were watching
when they hit their food
and the now come back later to move those foods to new hiding places which the potential themes by definition don't
know about the new hiding places we've shown that when it comes to social awareness.
They go to great lengths to protect their hidden food from being stolen by others. So for example.
We've been able to show that if other birds. Watching.
Not only do they move them to new places when the on the beds of come back
but they will also have specifically hired the food in shady spots rather than well lit places which are much harder
for the onlooker to see and in fact in a way we discovered there was we had a B.B.C.
One film crew can't they were filming for a series called Child of Our Time
and the cameraman got very frustrated because Sweetie Pie who was a very tame beautiful script I would wait
and an only had food every time a cameraman had to take a toilet break.
And eventually I had to say to the cameraman look away at an hour tell you when to start recording
and that was the only way we could film her and then we noticed that she was only hiding in the the places in the.
Reader that were well lit
and that gave us the idea to actually test where she specifically choosing shady places one observers were present
and we found that sure enough if another bad point or human was looking.
She would selectively cash in the shade of spots. And so would all the other birds we tested.
Where as if she was cashing private she was happy to cash in sunny and shady spots.
We've even shown that these kind of catch protection tactics that the parents do say moving with cash is hiding in
and shady spots and so on and so forth
and they're only done by experienced parents naive parents who've had no experience of stealing his don't do it.
So it's not just a hard wired. Instinctive ability more evidence that it's theory of mind that you.
Once you've had the experience of stealing yourself you can put yourselves in wooden shoes
and go Oh well if I was that bed. I would be watching where there is cash is where I'd come back and still.
So I better leave them to new places but they only engage in statics when they themselves have been themes.
It's really quite impressive but that sounds very interesting
and you convince me of some of those travelling very smart or capable of thinking.
A problem solving problems but what are you interesting interesting in how. Crowds. Because of family. Things or.
Does the deal in the end I want to find out how we think.
Both both so I would argue in the same way as if you want to know how a computer works.
You wouldn't want to only use an Apple not you'd want to also look at how a P.C.
Works and see the similarities
and differences in your types of computer in order to have a better understanding of how computers work in the same way
I'm going to have a better understanding I think about how our brains where.
If I look at similarities
and differences between crows in people because they crows are very distantly related to us we share a common ancestor
with them over three hundred million years ago. Well.
We as humans we as mammals it depends how you want to look at it but
but Danson mammals had a common ancestor over three hundred million years ago.
So there's been a long time in our evolutionary history in which we've been diverging moving
and down different paths and the. Our brains and those of other mammals are layered so our cortex has six layers to it.
Whereas the bird brain is doesn't have layers it's nucleated So the analogy might be that a bird brain
and a mammalian brain are a human brain. They are both full of these nerve cells which are so important.
Full thinking processes and my analogy would be if I imagine cakes. The.
Brain is like a fruit cake and the mammalian brain is like a six layered Austrian chocolate cake the subtlety.
So they're both made of cake mix but the structure or the layout the the architecture is actually quite different.
So that one raises interesting questions about whether those different new architectures might have might impose
different constraints on our thinking patterns. Well. What did you learn from across. So far. Well. Many things.
So firstly we've learned that they have really sophisticated cognitive abilities so there were a number of things that
were thought to be unique to human beings so at one time it was said that to manufacture is uniquely human
and the knife discovered. Well known seems to all's we've now found that.
All the crows that we've tested all the different species will happily use tools
and even make them even though they don't necessarily use tools in the wilds of New Caledonian crows.
Rely heavily on tools to find food in the wild but works and Jerry is down.
They will use
and make tools in the lab if they're given a task that requires one thousand you can stimulate the thinking process.
Yes So you know normally work has a very long bail and the kinds of foods they eat.
Are usually things like earthworms in the soil so for that you don't need a tool you just need to insert your big deep
into the soil and they have patches around their houses which are commonly
and adaptation for being able to dig the earthworms and other grams that are in the soil
but for that event we don't need to chill. But if you get.
There a task in the lab where they will need to chill in order to reach the food they will happily use tools
and make tools. Don't. Can we see that.
You do have any proof or evidence or I can show you some video footage of books spontaneously taking a piece of wire
and bending it into a hawk to retrieve a bucket.
That's out a bit which I can show you works in Jayne's using stones
and other objects to raise the water level to get worms.
So the so we don't travel the world in travel so we've got we've got what video footage
and powerful we can show you a lot to morrow and hundreds of police Great copies of anything so light.
How do we as humans are a species benefit from our from what you learn from growth. How do we benefit. Well.
I think people are fascinated by animals.
And you know a lot of people would love to go far away and see chimpanzees in the wild making tools
and interacting with your lovely our brother.
Footage the whole idea that that these other day pass are actually in the back garden.
It's pretty pretty stunning in thinking that you can actually watch them.
Solving problems and interaction
and it's not just sure you know that was one thing that was levied is uniquely human we now know it's not.
And why is that interesting. Well it's one of a number of things that we thought was perhaps responsible for.
How we've come to get our sophisticated cognitive abilities but if these birds have it too. Then we're not unique.
So EVA that means that I'm not.
More animals out there have it than we thought or it means that only a select few have it
and in which case probably these abilities have evolved in very different calibers with very different brains
but probably for similar reason that.
That raises the question What is that similar reason is it because of needing to be innovative problem solvers.
And therefore to be able to. Make sure if we need them.
Or is it because of our complex social lives the fact that we've form long term relationships with others.
That we're very good at being able to detect. Who's honest and who's cheating.
We're able to form alliances and political maneuvers to strengthen our chance of overcoming our enemies.
Politics is a good example of that we know that the chimpanzees form complex relationships alliances
and can do these kind of primate politics.
More recently we discovered that these call these numbers of the crow family and the Ravens and gays can do.
Form these complex social relationships.
So I think it raises I like him can you give examples to the social relations are you going to follow along for example
while I perfectly life that's for sure.
And I've been very worried when I I remember when two of our chapter
or so you're like this because the chapters were named after its solitaire so we had Nico Tintagel and Conrad Duran's.
And when Konrad Lorenz Starlight the capital Conrad Lawrence as opposed to the human Konrad Lorenz Nico was our.
Absolutely devastated and just stopped eating and could hardly hardly move for about a week
and I was really worried we were going to lose him. Eventually he was all right.
But it looked to me like emotional devastation of course it's very difficult to know exactly how you would say whether
the bird was in love but certainly in terms of their behavior.
It was it was consistent with being in love and then being bereft. They they usually pair for life.
So for me it's very stable long term monogamous relationships because it's also a process that they have.
Well certainly and things that track it was it Farrah Porton refuted defendant and nest travertine and have offspring.
It helps to.
You know I'm trapped all does is right down the bottom of the pecking order so you don't want to just find a mate
produce young and then go off and then find another one money and
when you need that mean really need to stay as a couple.
We also know in the chains for example that during the breeding season the male will feed the female
and this courtship It is very common in a number of birds.
It's just that in the jail is they do it very delicately which means that we can actually see
and I can show you footage of this. What's the male feeds the female.
So we can we can actually see the items physically being transferred from his beak to her being so we can count what
kinds of food and how many so we can quantify the food sharing
and what we've been able to show in a series of experiments is that the male J.I.
Is able to feed the female what she wants even if that's different to what he wants. So for example.
If I've just seen to help box of chocolates and it's and then you've maybe left a couple at the end.
So I'm pretty sure your fault of chocolate. Even though I like chocolate.
I could infer that you done with the chocolates now you're probably going to want something different to eat.
Well the Jays can can also do that they can ignore their own desire of what they want in order to cater for what their.
Female ones. Do you can use to say that thinking is an evolutionary process.
So if it if it develops in the mind in the crow's mind across brain.
Can you say that our own thinking is developing as well. Is that there can you develop thinking.
Yes I mean you know young children are not record at certain aspects of thinking.
So for example children before the age of four don't understand what a lie is because they can't understand that your
point if you can be different from our point of view.
So there's a famous task called the Sally Ann task which will demonstrate for you tomorrow that illustrates this way
you ask a little child. You say there is one dollar that has seen an item being hidden in one box and then the.
Dolly goes out the room.
And then the food is the move from that box to a new box a little child learn to understand that Sally who left the
room doesn't know that the child has moved here because of Sally saw as it go in the first box the little child will
assume that Sally knows just what she knows which is that the toy is now in this box not in that box
and similarly young children. Don't have a concept of yesterday and tomorrow or.
Either of those things the ability to think about other minds
and to think about other times those two things don't develop until children reach about the age of forty
but I mean of course. You know. People's lives thinking develops. But I mean for our species.
I don't think the development is in one of the thousand year or a million years. Do we have.
Development of a crime if the well that's an interesting question isn't it. The extent to which I think changes.
At one level you could sort of say well look our brains haven't really changed much in an instant.
Since the beginning in humans.
If you like
and so that's probably a sense in which we're not any more intelligent now it's only the way that we're that what I'm
going to give you to alternative arguments.
OK said that one case would be our brains haven't changed so probably at least since our ability to read
and write our thinking skills haven't improved we're probably no more or less intelligent than we were then.
The other line of argument for me to say well I don't know not whether or intelligence per se has changed
but our thinking patterns may well have done that whole notion that we live in a digital age water's locked on to our
brains so most people I think tend to remember telephone numbers any more.
You just pick an interval phone and you say actually this and press the button. And.
We have computers and i Phones and i Pads that and the hours to record information in ways which I think.
It's fundamentally changing how we think I'll give you just one example in an area that that I happen to know about
which courses dance and in both contemporary dance sound in. Ballet.
When you buy me develop a new choreograph it work in the old
and everything used to be written down through particular notation for example a lot of notation.
And of course there was a bit of ambiguity. When you come to reinterpret the story.
So if you go back in Latine original permitted in for when you want to make a new production it's ramen dead
and he hasn't twelve the new you want to stick as closely to what you. You think was meant by their original tabular G.
It's all a series of of notations which describe the basic moves
but obviously that's going to be some ambiguity in what those things mean in the same way as if you're if film many
care
and you want to develop a new version of a particular series based on the book of course there's the information in the
book but then said layers on top of that that need interpreting but of course these days in dance.
What most choreograph is do is to record it.
So now you don't have that same level of interpretation you just watched the video footage of the piece so that's a way
in which our thinking probably has changed.
I think there are a lot of people is that my area that there are a lot of people obviously something things like how
Twitter and Facebook and those forms of social media are affecting the way in which. Our social into. Actions where.
So.
But but don't you say I don't know if our thinking develops
and maybe in the future we will develop another way of thinking well that's a really exciting question I think was well
the question of whether by understanding more about how we think now we could find new ways of thinking.
So I think that's the golden look at that it's very interesting to think with words and with outward
and see what I do with Clive working on the Capital One of our think goals are big picture blue skies question is
whether under what extend it's possible to think beyond words.
And that's why we're so interested in looking at the constraints on our cognition.
And the patterns of thinking to see if that would generate new ways of thinking. Yes it's what.
You know it's one of the main goals of art is to examine ideas and.
So I think one of the things we're interested in is looking at constraints on our memories
and our perceptions as being the first baby steps in that direction because that's a basic eyes question.
We're not going to solve that question that we might get it a step closer to it. So it's trying to understand you know.
Why is it we missed so much of what happened and we missed so much of what we see in there
and I think that's really interesting question and we miss a lot.
Yeah but many of them will work and if we didn't all magicians would be out of business. Wouldn't I.
Because a magic effect capitalizes on the fact that there are a number of things that go well in a sequence that.
We miss if we saw every move that the magician and they in executing the fact. It wouldn't work as a magic trick me go.
Thanks a lot. You know why you're wasting my time.
It's the fact that we we know very well that the heart literally of vanished in thin air and yet our eyes
and our visual cortex our mind is telling us that that's precisely what time is always a challenge between facts
or magic and and are we think well that's just one example.
Another example would be with memory and perhaps I don't want to say too that gently catch Clive
and I interrupting because it's probably more powerful than two of us
but there's a phrase we really like to use which is you don't remember what happened.
What you remember becomes what happened.
So the whole idea that actually and we all know this when you say that
and yet you don't remember what happened what you remember becomes what happened.
So I think many people have had the sex parents live not seen a friend for years.
And you revenues about an event that you guys went to it was in their in their mental events and you.
You know it's a treasured memory for both of you and you start comparing notes about the event
and you realize that your memory is involved don't match totally you know that's interesting you know you have a memory
that. She was wearing a beautiful pair of rug shoes aren't she's never no they were black.
And she has a memory of it that you had a glass of champagne music. No no I was drinking.
I was driving I was just drinking coconut water and you like but how can this be. How can I remember it's.
And these are good friends you know we thought we thought thought similarly at others I'm not sharing this with an
alien from another planet
and one of you know it was my mistress the Bayshore head was just inaccurate you suddenly realize that the whole
mismatches have false memories where it. Is a is a can you compare thoughts.
With something like something unique like your eyes or you or your face or. Is it. If you need a way you think.
Well I think memory is a unique. Yes.
And I think it's very interesting that we often think of memory as being an accurate repository of the past
but it isn't our memories are extremely subjective and they're seeing through our own eyes so.
In our work with the caption thought.
Crime and I talk about memory as being the door to identity because our memory shape who we are.
And our identities our individuality shapes the way in which we choose to record. And remember.
Those instances that become our memories and that's why we don't remember what actually happened.
We have a subjective take on it. We remember those dates that interest and relevance to us.
And quite often we can discover that there are aspects of our memory that didn't even happen at all
or happened in quite a different way and we can do that by sharing our memories of Alice
and discovering that there are bits of my memory and your memory of the same event but don't match
and there's a lot of research that's been done on the notion of forms.
Memory by Elizabeth Loftus where she's found that. The way in which you. Phrase a question can.
Bias people to remember things in quite a different way from the way it actually happened.
So you might show somebody certain footage of an event that sets a car going.
At twenty miles an hour or forty miles an hour.
But actually the way in which you phrased the question afterwards that the car smashed into the Lhari
or the car bumped into the lorry will have a much more dramatic impact on the memory that person has of the event
but the actual speed that the car was going. False memory.
You know as you know as women are up more or less it's doesn't mean that the way we remember them.
You said that determines our identity. That's right. So it's very personal. When you think. Yeah yeah.
Memories are subjective experiences. So there are no two memories alive from different persons. Well I think.
They're all different you know even if it is a loved one with whom you are very close and
and you know feel that you sink in the same way your memories are still going to be slightly different because you know
they're seen through a different set of eyes
and they're being filtered through a different mind because everybody's experiences are different from one another so I
think even two identical twins would still have slightly different memories. Oh oh well that's that's interesting.
I never I never looked at it like that. I thought well if you have been of the same. Occasion and you must think.
But we put our own subjective stamp on it
and that's I think where integrating science funding arts to study these kinds of questions becomes so important
and so insightful because it's easy as a scientist just to think very objectively and go.
These these are the things that are being remembered that that has a list of things that happened in this event
happened in this particular room at this time on a particular day.
She was wearing this he was wearing that but that's not how our memories were not just a series of labels.
She was effect a series of facts it's about me the emotional experience
and that's the difference perhaps between that's one aspect of why I would call it a thought
and a series of facts so we labels it extremely crude be extremely objective
but your thoughts are personal of my subjective
and sometimes they can change depending on how you're feeling on a particular day. So you may revisit a memory.
In consequence of which you actually change it.
You don't just revisit it and go down the list of things that happened
but all of a sudden because of something else you've discovered in the interim
or because of a different mood you're in your well being. You reshape it. So when you say that the sexual.
Memory or the. Affection remember our objective but because who you are and. Because. The time. That the It Gets.
Filtered through your mind. It's subjective and. That's that's how the form is created.
Well sort of I think it's a bit more complex than that. I mean. How Yeah.
Because I sing A Well I think there are of actual labels that we remember with precision.
London for capital of England. No idea how I know that information.
I don't have a memory of how and then the information but it's just something I know. And that's not going to change.
I'm not going to revisit my knowledge that. The fact that London is a couple of England.
That's not going to change that
but much of our memories are not purely factually based they have all these other components to them.
And the difference there.
I think arises because we've each got a new unique pair of eyes
and a unique mind that filtering all those things as as you said
but I think it's also because we're selective in our attention. So we also don't see everything that's going on.
And therefore another reason why we might have different memories of the event quite aside from with different eyes
and different minds is that my viewpoint of what I see is different to your viewpoint.
What you see so we can both be looking at the bird and I know that.
When you're looking at the does that stuff behind me that you're going to see
and similar you know that what I'm looking at the bird.
I can see Clive
and I can see the background wall over there which is not something that you can see at the moment because you're
looking at the bird and you're looking at me.
So that's a selective attention difference as well as a filtering difference.
So that's what I meant to submit there I think the instance of that surely.
Well when you when you try to research crowds. For children. How hard is it to try to understand alien brains.
Yes well it's is it.
But I suppose it depends on your point of view I spent so many years trying to think about what it's like to be a bird
that to me it's not very alien at all.
But at another level of course Italian because however hard I try to imagine what it's like to be a crow.
I'm not a crow and I never will be sadly.
And however much I think about how children might be thinking it's a long time. Sadly to the time I was a child.
And even
when I was a child I wasn't the same as the children I'm investigating because we have all these individual subjective
differences we've been talking about. So all you can do scientifically I think is to present various kinds of problems.
And ask how the subjects be them crows or children
or adult humans are solving the task that's what you're trying to do you are trying to get what the constraints on the
thinking are what the milestones are and how how much individual differences there are
and what those milestones are both within children and within the closed. Well what exactly are you looking for.
I don't know what you mean by that. Well.
Somehow there isn't you feel the need to do to research this find out how thinking worse and.
And somehow try to find that kind of secret because you don't know. And you want to find out. That's right. And so.
I'm interested in knowing what the constraints are on our thinking processes.
And thinking about but is there a reason why you you do this.
Well I've always wanted to know what it's like to think like a bat that's for sure
but I'm also interested in knowing whether there are new ways of thinking that we're not aware of
but by understanding better what some of these constraints are on our thinking processes that make that might give us
clues into what these new ways of thinking might be
and that's where the work that I do with Clive on the capture thought that's
when that is so critical because by bringing in these different perspectives
and trying to understand more about what those fundamental features are.
That might help us better understand how we could improve our thinking skills
or thinking new way is that we not aware of at the moment. Are you able to think in different ways. Yes I think so.
I mean I think so you can thing in words but
but I think most of us can think without words as well as of us a century before you know when Clive
and I don't seem to go together. I'm not but I try to understand because. If I think.
Well I probably thinking words but but I never had a thought about it.
So I try to be aware of the the different ways I can think. OK Well all of us can think you know.
Well let me try it with an example and have something more simple. You like Mike. So imagine.
I've just put you a glass of wine you take a sip of it. And it's really nice. It's the nicest wine.
You can ever remember tasting you have this gorgeous experience.
Words are really going to describe for you that experience of the taste of that exquisite why.
You know we we use artificial words do you say don't we say this one's got lots of cherries in black currant But you
know it's a glass of wine and it's made from grape juice there aren't any cherries or black currents really in there.
These They're only labels that we're trying to attach to these things to share our experiences of this thing that it's
really an experience it's not and
and the words are only have a rough approximation of the way of sharing the experiences.
So that's the kind of thing that both I mean.
Somehow just putting words only in the same way as that sent with with the tongue or you know just saying.
Clive let me until that point up show us something.
It doesn't describe the exquisite experience of dancing tango it's just a label folk.
Whether apartment forwards or backwards.
It doesn't really capture it captures an tiniest little aspect of the words for sure. Words for sure.
For thinking but thinking. I never looked like that. Is it possible not to think. Yes when you died.
I think it's pretty impossible not to think when your life whether you are aware of the thoughts is another matter.
So there are you know interesting cases of people who don't necessarily have conscious access to their thoughts.
A classic case of that would be.
You know nominees it needs to be a memory loss he doesn't have access to they've witnessed the events
but somehow the events haven't been I don't have conscious access to what happened at all. All patients are blind side.
I can see that they're not sure where but they can see so if you ask them.
Did you see that I said No no I haven't seen you haven't seen anything.
I'm blind but then if you say I just guess that highly accurate.
So that I have seen it but my brain has it registered the information that they've actually seen it.
Have you ever considered the thought that when you die. The only thing that virus is your are your thoughts. No a.
Just come up with that because you say well you stop thinking when you're dead but maybe then
when your body dies you understand what I mean yeah but where would those thoughts go.
I don't know the trying to think out loud.
Just maybe that would be interesting because because because it's it's hard not to think.
This or that because they're carrying on the culture and in society.
You know it's as if it might be a hope for example doesn't it.
It's a bit hard to tell if you answer the questions and we're going to film you. Yes that no no I talk.
I'm just having some think you're great. Yeah OK. Also you know why didn't they didn't listen to it.
Well maybe you can I was probably prompting you to ask your US Next question. OK People are certain that.
The thoughts of one person don't necessarily die when they die if there's ideas are culturally relevant.
OK I don't know. Yeah. Conflict of the Yeah Yeah. Thank you. Don't ask you don't know what's good for you. Yeah.
So that's that's not so young. Yeah I suppose that's where and then real is a shared experience comes in. That.
Oh so well. So where does it come in memory as a shared experience comes in. The whole idea of thought.
Although your source and your memories are individual that pestilent subjected to you.
You can on the last share them with Alice and in multiple way you can share
and then by discussing with one another like we're doing here.
You can share them by creating something exquisite like a Beethoven symphony that neighbor's yard long.
Long after Beethoven himself or a beautiful piece of beautiful piece of literature that.
The author dies
but nonetheless all of those thoughts as represented in the novel remain so in all those ways the thoughts can live on.
Although of course there's a sense in which they live on in a sense in which they died because the subjective
experience of the originator of the thought there is still it's a guide but the shared experience of the thoughts
and the way in which thought and thoughts are interpreted by others and evolved
and I suppose that's what history does you have these ideas that are recorded
but actually as others really visit the history. Just as a memory is changed and it's really a city and so is history.
So are the thoughts. So there's a level at which they live on but they don't they are changed but they also get richer.
Somehow because right now we know this music in this music in this music and. Still we manage to do to make new.
Music which is beautiful. Yeah.
And the way in which it's interpreted will change because of the new technologies because of the new experiences. So.
In a way these thoughts
and these memories are much more than just this little snippet of factual accurate information about the past day
infuse and.
Pervade our history and our culture good and bad and good and bad and their evolution if you like as a species.
So why do you want to fly. I don't know how to party in two words really.
I've always been fascinated by what it's like to be. That I've always been fascinated with.
Being able to move in a straight and she well instead of being stuck on Terra for.
It's just feels like it's a fundamental feature of me and yet somehow I have difficulty verbalizing it.
Perhaps because they kind of subjective experiences and thoughts associated with wanting to fly
and wanting to be a bed are largely worthless. So what is it. For the on word. So I want. So let's let's hope.
But somehow there must be origin of you as a thinking or I would like flight since the Freedom is not a minute.
Whole idea of being able to.
Explore the world from up above to be in the sky and look down and see more and see further.
And to see that you could how much totally different perspective on how the world looks you still have this wish.
Yeah man. Somehow I don't have words that really do it justice. It's this isn't what you have all your life.
And how do you keep this a life or do you keep it a life or do you need just idea to keep on going. I turn like that.
It's just part of me it's you know what I do.
I don't think of flying like a burka Oh there's something in you inside you. Which in which. We're just friends.
We all have our spirituality don't we.
We all have those things that we identify as being sort of cool features of ourselves.
For different people and different things but. Yeah. So.
When we go to morrow to this lab we will see a lot of children.
But yeah I know that we're doing children tomorrow on the day after our live also Scotland program.
So what what do you hope to find out with these tests or. Procedures or.
Well let's talk about that
when we do that because there's lots of different one thought so I would rather clear direct with the stuff you have
said it's almost it's going to be a bit there something just doesn't gel but I think.
So when you dance you dance everywhere watching me. Well did you dance outside of it at home or at the lab or.
At a club or this dancing you mean this tangled. Well you do that we go to the longest which I toss.
And that's the main place you think. And we do them enough to form it says. I know that sometimes we don't know.
The last question of why the tango because you're both not from Argentina.
Gosh I don't know how to answer that you don't really it's her supposed movement I think it's such a beautiful dance
because it's you so connected with it.
Partly it's like they talk about it as being for legs
and animal with four legs into beating hearts because they are so connected. So.
You know there's many forms of dance and tight. I love that you know.
Ballet salsa is great fun
but there's something very powerful about it because of the connection you have with your partner so the leader
and follow and the way in which he responds along to the music.
I think it's very very special that every child just have this artist inside.
So he deserves every artist every scientist have an artist inside.
But it's not very common is it to be a scientist around the artist in residence somewhere
and equally of course you know the way.
Clive is artist in residence in the psychology department so I think we've got something that is quite unique.
You need a hearing with artist in residence
but typically that short term residences of three months old at most a year
and usually it's the artist comes into your place talks to people and then creates a. Piece of art.
Where is I think the captured thought the work that Clive and I do.
Is truly collaborative it's not time comes and has a cup of coffee with me and then create something
and I have a chat with time go off and do an experiment and occasionally we meet up and talk about them.
I mean the whole project that we've been hearing it's is.
Interwoven together so all our talks are written and jointly and performed jointly and it's it's. Fifty percent.
You know you but think of it as being fifty percent making fifty percent Clive the really it's more like two percent
and eighty two percent. Clive and ninety six percent. Nick inclined integrated and two percent.
I'm only saying because you know obviously one voice is speaking while the other is silent and vice versa.
But all of those all the thoughts and all the ideas are a collaborative mixture.
And I hope and I think that as a result. It's like a gestalt phenomenon.
We're being able to share more and do more than either of us could do you alone.
I certainly feel that I wouldn't have got nearly so far in my thinking about science.
If it hadn't been for Clive and I collaborating and it's not just on our discussion here in there.
It really is this integrated into woven working together and thinking together.
And trying to make new connections between disparate sources that alone. I wouldn't have thought of. But together.
With Clive and we you know we can kind of push each other to explore further. So that's why I feel that it's.
It's more than what you normally see in collaboration it's it's it's an integration.